yeah get that shot I haven't vlogged in
a while I've been really sick for the
past week so this is pretty much just
going to be a vlog of what goes on today
and what happened maybe in the past
couple days I'm not even sure what
footage I have but today we're shooting
a bunch of cooking videos for the next
few weeks so this is a spoiler alert
look at you little doggy
oh you're so sweet you so sweet does he
hide everyone hmm say hi to the vlog
Cody oh this is exciting I can't show
you guys it well I do so good matter one
right where you are okay this is our
second video of the day myself present
open up a new bowl really stepping up
the cooking game here just you know
learning the ways eating in a lap dog
you look so suspect likes but he loved
it did he jump up there
oh he does that so he'll just jump off
and be like I'm loving it
Jen what are you making oh my gosh red
velvet cookie get our red velvet cookie
hey I'm trying to like you know prep
videos for you guys it's a struggle
cause usually I go day by day it's like
cool what am I going to make today
this is what we're going to do in here
or how much do you need oh um let's see
getting you guys a night behind the
scenes tour heroes oh god where is it we
go I don't really feel takes that long
see sugar
finally done shooting for the day we got
a bunch of videos ready and I'm excited
I just wanted to show you guys a quick
little behind-the-scenes since this vlog
is sort of just a casual little vlog sub
give you a quick little walk through
this is a lovely prep table I started
using these little kitchen trays our
refrigerator tubs
to put all my gadgets in so this is sort
of like the audio section solar audio
cables will go in there so you usually
do a two camera setup so I've been using
the a 7s mark - I'm using this Sony
microphone it connects to the hot cue
and it has two XLR input which allowed
me to use these microphones and then
when I'm cooking or filming and
sometimes I'm filming by myself because
I can't actually see what I'm doing so I
hook this a small HD camera right into
the sky move this forward so I can see
what I'm doing while I'm filming and
then if Cody isn't here to help me film
and I'm filming by myself I have the
second camera here which you can see in
the previous video that I posted where I
had these two right next to each other
so I'd have the second camera on this
one so I'll be able to see those cameras
still cook that onto video
so this is a behind the scenes of a
cooking video yeah we've got mess mess
mess mess
camera camera monitor so I can see
what's going on and just more mess just
a lot a lot of months we've got
batteries charging non-stop yeah this is
good the worst part about clinical
videos is having to clean up what I'm
doing that right now but I'm also going
to be taking this camera upstairs
because I'm going to shoot a couple
unboxing videos today as well will
respond about the sony a7s or - the
battery life let's head upstairs to set
up the unboxing station and record look
this will die full centres leather wrap
you need anything
oh shoot I have the wrong lens on him ah
which lenses because when I'm at my
unboxing station admit there's not much
room so I have to use a wide-angle one
the ones that I use for that I believe
is a 16 to 35 prep high
so going to need this guy's also going
to need this one this one these two
there we go how to change everything
back because Cody keeps on manual and I
do not I have to show you everything
auto because I am shooting by myself so
I can't do everything at the same time
learn this little guy one button here
I'm going to be able to see what's going
on let me see my second on roof and that
lighting is not good alright I gotta
bring that light up now side the Rafah
cut the light right here mm-hmm
is like color work Oh beautiful not much
better okay you've got a set up Mike
everything
audio is not working shoot the mics not
plugged in so of course it's not going
to work
hello hello uh only one sides working it
really is a lot easier to have to learn
how to do this
ouch and I hurt my foot let's do the
trick hello hello
yep now they're both working and I've
got my baby here to say hi we've got our
backup batteries on deck not going to
clean up this desk and there's only time
to choose an unboxing video or two
that's how it's done
when I want to our second unboxing video
I just completed one the quick little
preview of what it is you know what it
is and my computer downstairs and I
gotta reset up my desk because I
predominantly have been using the new
MacBook Pro my main reader given my desk
complete with drinks that I haven't
thrown away like it would put my laptop
here so I'd if you want of a Dom Bowl to
convert USBC expecting use my monitor so
I plug that into here this is my hard
drive goes to here this is my charger
and here's my USB hub connects to here
but thankfully excuse me a few more USB
slots in the back so I'm able to not
have to use the dongle I could just use
be cables on my monitor left that and
now I save all my footage and I start
editing yeah it's really great that's
that super simple huh
thank you for watching I'll see you guys
soon in all the videos that I'm about to
edit for you bye
Brian just develop done I guess it was a
great time to ask you guys who do you
want to win the Super Bowl Patriots or
Falcons we've got one last cupcake here
and I decided to save this one because
this is a very very very special cupcake
this one is for Tom Brady and we're
going to call this but the flight cake